crab feast you know what it's all about
I'm yelling you ain't gotta ask me cuz
you could trust that every Tuesday you
already
Juuko above goes better than most J
Lawson self-diagnose go down low this
week last week here we go again crab
feast
welcome back to the crab feast y'all
thank you so much
no the Tuesday crappy spoke rough out of
the gate there for a little wd-40 on it
ride it man try to find your player
trying to find you feasting nation J
Lawson comedy here J Lawson calm be calm
chill out some comedy on Facebook
Pinterest Instagram and MySpace play
it's good to be here with your I great
to be here with future nation I love you
and I'm just at home with my my family
I'm not really doing stand-up if I'm in
town I'll promoted it for in town dates
but I'm not going anywhere I want to be
home right Ryan Sickler on Twitter and
Instagram Ryan Sickler official on
Facebook Ryan Sickler com st. Louis I
will be there this Friday night Friday
night 11 6 I'm covered to the loot at
Blueberry Hill doors open at 8:00 show
at 9:00 you can get tickets on my
website the crab feast calm and Mound
City calm Reno Sam Tripoli and I are
doing a couple of shows oh I should say
Nevada Reno we're gonna be there on Reno
the 19th Vegas the 20th you can get info
on my website and the craft is calm as
well and December 26th and 27th I'm at
the Brea improv we're doing three shows
right after Christmas I'm working to
keep it affordable so if you live in
Southern California you have family and
friends in town for the holiday bring
them out we'll have a lot of fun out
there for any and all crab feast info
the crab feast calm thank you so much
for all your help with breast cancer
awareness you guys really are the best
fans and it's nice to see you guys
taking it you know yeah we put it out
there so we can do something and you
guys put it out there so you can do
something it's nice to have a community
that we have yeah so thank you guys we
truly appreciate you will be making a
donation to breastcancer.org and you can
help the merch store today all orders
include free domestic shipping in a flat
$10 international fee and for those you
to procrastinate your Christmas shopping
don't do it early art now use our Amazon
link get on your Christmas shopping now
we do where Amazon Prime now yeah I am -
I was on prime and we get you can get
that delivered in two hours you know I
just saw that I was get ready to joke
and say that you can do here like how
where is unbelievably must have like a
storage facility two hours bottom line
is I'm always like two days before
Christmas scrambling I'm not gonna be
this year man yeah don't you be go to
the Amazon lamb with rhyme you can send
it back on free almost everything dude
with Prime I had a guy come over the
other day and I just look at premium
episodes are available on iTunes and for
Androids
and non iTunes users on Gumroad episodes
or a dollar ninety-nine and listen we've
been getting a lot of hit up quite a bit
about Google Play we are going to be on
Google Play but Android users you don't
need you can still listen to us you can
go mom yeah I mean come on a lot of you
were hitting us up like Oh for Andrew
you can listen right now there's nothing
stopping Android users from listening
and go to the site there's plenty of
options you can get an app like stitcher
and listen that way as well thank you
for all the love on the Facebook fan
page and the iTunes page and make sure
you follow all things comedy on social
media and one of the things that we've
been getting a great response on that
we're excited about is the video
submissions that we Borland yeah we're
working on a project we've been getting
some great videos out there from you
guys keep it to a minute or less hey
listen we know you ladies are out there
we know that you're out there you just
might be a little shy fellas you've been
hitting us up big-time and it's great
we'd really love to get a selection of
what feature nation's all about so
anybody out there it's got a fun
interesting story give us a little bit
about it and tell us about yourselves
yeah you know we video over us over know
how we do it here we travel adventure
stories near-death experience done I
always have to be a drinking story
arrests domestic and/or abroad haunted
stories revenge stories saving a life or
having your life saved craziest thing
you ever saw or witnessed whatever we're
looking for the best stories from the
best storytellers so if you're
interested send us around on one minute
Oh tell us who you are where you live
and a little bit about your story send
all of your submissions to crab feast
podcast at gmail.com perfect again back
this week one of our favorite sponsors
touch of modern comm you guys want to be
the trends that are in your group and by
that you want to have the coolest stuff
in your ends like - would you get that
what are you wearing where'd you get
that touch of modern calm is what
everyone needs to be going to to get
your style on track touch remaining calm
connects directly with top designers
timeless and unique products each item
is hand selected to grab your attention
which I've said there's a hundred times
it's one of my favorite things about it
is it's not just like let's throw a
bunch of crap on there then like right
this is fresh let's get it and we put it
on and it's not gonna last long that's
another thing about it the site it's not
something that's gonna sit there and get
stale on the Shelf it's there for a
while as soon as it runs out they're
like boom what's on to the next thing
they're curating this site it's not just
a bunch of crap so what you need to do
you want jaw-dropping tech gadgets and
gear sleek iPhone case I catching new
and vintage watches with that's the
other thing right it's not like they
just have all these like brand new
things he's a vintage watches you can
get that y'all exes like things you
think you could only get like at an
antique store or like at a jewelry store
they have some really cool stuff new
sales literally launching every day
tetramand calm is the one website to
discover and elevate lifestyle in a
single click right now our listeners get
immediate access when they sign up at
touch of modern calm that's touch'
Montcalm do today because tomorrow it'll
all be different and that's how life
moves in the fast lane I tell you
something else who moves in the fast
lane this week's guest three timer this
week yes dude I'm fighting right and we
are excited he told us he keeps a list
in his phone when he gets stories ready
to tell and that's always the best guest
you guys love them and you know please
welcome back on the crab feast I mean
it's one too many times that's for damn
sure but we're excited regalis please
welcome back the crab feast mr. Daniel
Van Kirk dvtv
timer yeah yeah this is the third time
three times too many last time in your
ear wolf studios as a matter of fact no
last time was here first times you're
right every time the lady none of us
great song about oh yeah I mean yeah get
out of my dreams and into my car get
into it well before we get we have
plenty to talk about plenty to talk
about very excited but before we do
please plug away well my name is Daniel
Van Kirk a three-time guest on the crab
feast well two right now
Oh cuz it might not if you're hearing
this the first part worked out you can
follow me at Daniel Van Kirk when does
it stop I know you guys get that a lot
we do know you okay
all right don't worry about it let's
just say it's polite JT went off 2016 oh
great my mini I'm in then the third week
of January I think that's like the 22nd
23rd I'll be up at sketch fest doing a
Walberg solution on Friday night and
then Saturday we're gonna be doing a
Sklar bro country county yes you have to
be determined how much of one show of
the other we're gonna do but I'll
definitely be doing that with the
sklar's what's the difference between
country and County
counties good country is a show it's the
sklar's they got a couple hot takes they
bring in a guest they do an interview
then the guest six-run they do a couple
quick takes and they're out county is
just hanging out microphones jackass I
think if you were if we were sitting
around having lunch right now I'm like
did you guys hear about the girl that
rode the turtle in Florida and then we
would just riff on that as we would in
normal life usually what happens in
writers rooms before somebody says
alright guys we gotta get some work done
today that part so it's just the sklar's
from me and it's been both of you at
numerous times you know what I want to
ask because I don't think the listeners
would like to know one thing I like
about you and there's not not a ton of
stuff so one thing is you do amazing
impressions it's debatable okay
decent impressions right but you're a
great story tell at the same time
usually like
you know but what is Walberg solution
cuz if people want to come up to it and
that's a really cool show just telling
somebody was essentially politically
incorrect if it was hosted by Mark
Wahlberg or even Bill Maher so I guess a
little bit the one that is now what is
it bill are real time with blue mark
so Mark Wahlberg invites his celebrity
friends onto the show by the way it's a
way Mark Wahlberg is he could do a show
like this
oh yeah he's not above it you know him
on the [ __ ] Wahlberg good I don't
understand what the deal is with
Benghazi somebody comes over to your
house and they start a fight with you
that's not your fault you gotta take
that defend you get to it
get some baseball bat since a broken
glass and Donnie yeah honey Donnie you
go out first
so yeah Wahlberg Wahlberg host is it mr.
Rhyne sickle you saw the very first one
at bridge town and yeah there's
different comedians being characters and
usually one comedian is themselves
you've done the show you're on the most
recent one I had agree uh which when we
were recording this will drop soon and
yeah they just come on I bring real news
topics and events like real stuff that's
happening down and then we just break it
down panel style and it gets dropped on
your wolf now a straight guy yeah right
you are so it's a fun show yeah yeah
awesome man well good to have you back
hey you know what it's been a great show
yeah man thanks for coming go ahead and
let the fans know where they can find
Daniel Van Kirk on Instagram and then
myspace - Danny Van Kirk you're still
out there
chorus I'm sure right it's all out there
I logged in I logged in you still kids a
time capsule is it I would love to do a
show where you bring up comedians and
get into their myspace for the first
time in 10 years yeah and just start
going through stuff Justin Timberlake
still post and [ __ ] it's all still there
yeah they reform at all but like all of
your pictures and posts that you made
and stuff are still there but the cool
glittery things with like a perfect
circle song playing isn't there anymore
but yeah you can see every song you ever
put on your myspace wall see I wasn't
very active I mean there's there's
pictures and stuff but mmm
myspace comes up in one of my stories
too doesn't
yeah well I want to start with Marshall
Field's yeah I mentioned this to you
when we wrapped last time and you were
like why that we were like why the [ __ ]
didn't you okay so by the way a lot of
comedians do yeah yeah soon as we're
done and like oh man there's this one
time like what the [ __ ] I got caught in
a 4x4 with Frank oh really that's a
story that just frickin your mind you
know it's fun I didn't know this but
Marshall Field's that was initially the
Beatles song before Strawberry Fields it
was my what Marshall Fields Bergen it's
it's the Macy's of Chicago but now it
literally is the Macy's of Chicago's
they bought Marshall Fields so on State
Street in Chicago that Gate Street the
Sinatra sang about there's a it's a city
block an entire city block is this store
they've got little windows to do for the
holidays people come home over and see
and check them out there's a huge like
green probably was copper now it's green
o'clock on the corner of like Washington
and state and it's huge
I mean it's 14 floors so after leash as
I talked about in the last episode I was
a ferret it's a federal agent too we
went through that right yeah okay so at
when the when after 9/11 and they moved
out to the suburbs and I couldn't be an
agent anymore I turned in my badge I
remember I just wanted the guy I might
have said this but I wanted my boss to
just like throw me against the wall and
call me a loose cannon make me turn in
my badge but it was really like yeah
just leave it there right and I I had a
guy who I met through people that I
worked with there and he he wanted to
become a cop but he as most people do
not most but a lot of people who want to
be cops they get jobs in security and so
he was a secret shopper a loss
prevention officer I know all about
and Marshall Lee and Chimayo live at
Marshall Fields and so they're like he
said oh dude you should come over here
and work you know we're hiring seasonal
people and then they'll probably keep
you on and so I went over that interview
now I'll break it down for you like I
said it's a city block the the basement
floor
it's a the lower floor I guess is
housewares a furniture and [ __ ] yeah no
well there is but this is all literally
all housewares an entire flow of house
words and then the other half of the
floor is like a food court
okay it's like a Harrods then and yeah
and then there's access to the subway
the Chicago subway system there's access
to that through the lower level it's a
little ped we well so you can snatch and
grab oh that's a thing imagine grab man
yeah coats that there's a reason I'm
telling you oh this is coach there's an
atrium there's where all your makeup is
and all the stuff there's big Christmas
trees right and then every floor has
like different themes - kids are on five
there's an entire bridal shop on four we
got a snatch-and-grab
so the l-train you get up to the seventh
floor now you get the walnut room this
is a five-star restaurant it's got this
40-foot Christmas tree in it the city
itself it is it is and the five-star
restaurant wars eight and nine furniture
showrooms and I mean just furniture
you'd look up there'd be like oh man we
got a hoist guys you're telling me the
two furniture showrooms I have furniture
all over let me set all those little
water the reason I distinguishes because
one is set up like showrooms like this
is your living room all done the others
just literally random [ __ ] couches
all over the place now so it's like that
[ __ ] upstairs yeah this is what how you
can organize what some tents more
offices okay 11th floor offices
12 13 14 factory because they used to
make
chocolates up there Franco mints and
they would make these and this was an
entire choc effect here this thing moved
out in the mid 70s nobody touched it you
know this is like corn it it just was
creepy as [ __ ] right floor work yes okay
I heard they shut down there was so many
snatch and grabs going on guys we out we
would have we would have cases we're
working there
we got people stealin Slyke we had
somebody stealing like Swarovski
crystals Faberge eggs and so they went
on eBay found one of the eggs bought it
won the auction big day when we get in
on that yeah this guy's like why is he
going so high it's not worth this so
they have it delivered to somebody's
house and then they bring it to police
station and these idiots didn't they
didn't wear gloves or anything when they
put it in the box so they had their
fingerprints they ended up catching the
people we had guys who they would they
would hide in the store wait till about
3:00 in the morning when the only people
there were the uniform loss prevention
people who wore like little fake cop
okay now here's my question how many of
you are covering a 14 story building
eight to ten at a time depending on the
business a real story yeah so you would
literally just wear whatever you want
when you would walk around all day
pretending to shop so you became for how
many hours a day oh eight to eight to
nine yeah depending on how big of a you
know so basically one of you per floor
cuz the other thing you always go on
friends cuz you need to look like a
couple of buddies you need to look at a
couple so if you ever like find yourself
actually just getting wrapped up in and
start shopping on some great deals the
other thing is we're lost prevention
your job is also that the the people who
work there they're stealing people were
stealing and then you have incidents in
the restaurant we had no old guy fell
into the great of the escalator just
peel this back yeah but you have
everything like you're saying it's like
a city everything is happening in this
stuff okay and everybody I'm working
with wants to be a cop so they are hard
or been feh this guy been fuh hardcore
about this white guy nope
he was like an Arabic Spanish guy and he
just was like just like don't [ __ ]
around then then we had this other guy
bill bill was like this big like a
third-generation police department and
he he's waiting to take his test and he
would when I got there
I'm he goes I you picked your desk buddy
and I'm like I'll go over he's like do
not sit there they a person you have
fired that desk as bad juju and so he
was and then they had a command center
like 735 inch tube TVs and for DIA and
you could see everything in the store
and one hour of your day when you
weren't walking around was here to
rotate and be the person at the command
center like because everybody had radios
yeah so you and they had a code for
everything right so that a oh and you
had a number so my number was 81 right
so nice Remo with the pad yeah that's
right anyone what's your 20 and freaked
out on the I what's your 20 81 and we
don't have your pieces you literally
have the little like over the shoulder
cop deal like 81 what's your 20 I'm like
um while you're shopping yeah but you
don't have to hide it like in your
jacket but I know exactly we're talking
about cuz I used to wear one too but
that's I mean yeah OD or something right
so we would run it up like your clip it
to your collar I'm trying to pick up
girl yeah would you say everyday
something was stolen from that sore had
have you write every day everything had
it there was never a day where nothing
was taken
and there were codes for the people who
were in the store okay mm-hmm so a white
person was a 99 we had a 1099 over on
fifth floor children's I got a 1099
every year for kid you know by person
1098 always man first time and rates
this mile 1097 1096 Asian or other
another yeah so you would say look
specific I got a 1098 female along with
the 1097 male they're currently walking
through and that the whole store is
broken up by quadrants or like there to
east
Randolph east side of the building
Randolph side and yeah and so you would
say that everything we're yeah and then
south southwest hey coach
got a 96 96 yeah you 1019 me you know
like 1036 we have 1036 that means we
think that they put something in their
bag
they codes need to learn for every
single thing you're not and I'm just a
kid going to college and I'm like you
guys federal agent yeah but even that
was a joke
I like this yeah this is way really
intense like really intense so one day
they sent me down I've been there about
a week and we've had stuff with the guys
stealing suits in the middle of the
night in Iran I mean still like five
grand suits ever any loss prevention
people steal Oh at all I'm sure it
happens yeah but me not on my watch
right so they go hey look then we didn't
tell you this when we hired you but
there's another part of your job you
gotta take care of and I'm like okay
what's this like well it's not a
commonly known thing but since the
mid-60s Marshall Field's has been an
underground meetup for people looking to
have sex it's mainly homosexual sex it's
meaning the guys but it's guys and girls
too I'm like what
and they're like yeah you know it used
to be that people couldn't come out
that's how our society was you as though
that was a life you kept in the shadows
breaking down society oh yeah yeah I'm
gonna tell you right now I hate for me
the judge and gave me can't hear that
happening over in the store you caught
two guys [ __ ] in a nightgown Rach
last week so I'm like what are you
wouldn't you timeline I'm all blown
snatchy
more of a grab and grab now if you're
lucky
snatch and snitch move left of the
camera 48 too big pad up so so I'm like
really they're like yeah but they've got
a 1016 a couple of code for everything
man they they they they have a couple of
meeting places so they say well
interested parties what they tend to do
is they meet at the atrium kind of feel
each other out then they'll go to the
second floor bathroom that's your main
bathroom
okay and I'm like alright I think so
what you need to do basically is just
every on the hour every hour just go
into each bathroom on each floor just
make sure that nothing's happening there
I'm like okay so I do this for a while
perfect I'm not picking up anything and
one day probably my within my first two
weeks of being there I'm finally
learning in all their codes you know i'm
10-19 from lunch meeting back from
laundry oh yeah
if they so I am ten seven I'm on lunch
whatever so I walk in the bathroom
nothing another bathroom nothing I walk
into the children's fifth floor bathroom
and I open that door and there's a ten
going oh what's the cold 81 and I'm like
there's I just
there's no I just
they go flying
they both come running out I come round
any one base I'm following a 1097
there's 1098 1097 scrolling down the
escalators
I'm sure chasing 1098 to think 1097 is
the middle of this atrium going back and
forth down the escalators running
running running he ends up getting out
I'm chasing 1088 he's going down to the
Basset I'll chase him to that Christmas
so then so remember I told you a uniform
security guards okay APO Garza that's
the uniform security guards they're a
POS
asset protection officers because you
can identify them this this 1088 comes
running through men's cologne towards
men's coats on the first floor and all
of a sudden APO Garza just comes around
from the other side leaps tackles him
over a table of Christmas presents in
Detroit takes out two trees yeah we take
we take him back up to our we got like
little holding areas for you on the
tenth floor where our offices are and we
take them in there he's like come on man
let my kids bathroom man I'm like the
cop the cops are on their way okay now
something to know about if you're in
downtown Chicago that's district 1 and
the cops who work district 1 don't have
to deal with [ __ ] because almost no
violent crime happens in district 1 it's
the only yeah it's Michigan Avenue it's
like there's pickpockets I'm sure
there's fights
well but it's not oh it's so not a
neighborhood really there's not a lot
happening so I'm like these cops get
here I'm here you're gone did you do
this in a [ __ ] like I you can live
whatever life you want a little bit
don't do this in a bathroom and a public
place let alone a children's floor and
believe his bill I saw the whole thing
so the cops come walk in and I'm like
officer how you doing officer he's
raised right here cop walks in the only
thing this cop says to this guy the only
thing he cares about he goes are you
doing man and the kids like fun and he's
like I just gotta know did you know
come on like no way that guy's there he
goes no man then he's like don't seem
worth it to me then the cop like that's
all the thing that he cared about did
this happened all the time and chill
like if kids would have walked in that
doing we automatically both of them or
sex offense oh yes this stuff happened
all the time did you not we all once
caught a lawyer who was Christmas
shopping with his family and he just
like you guys go I'll do one thing that
he went in the bathroom and started
fooling around with a guy and then we
had got girls doing it too one time they
were like I feel dumb for doing this now
but one time they were like 81 hey won't
we think this business going on third
for blessing and I'm like all right
so I go in there like go in there are
you shell-shocked to go in again what am
I gonna see here I'm like I've never
told this story I go into the third
floor I'm not like going there just
check it out and I'm like what you just
walk in there like no just going it like
sit down in a stall to see if anything's
happening so I walk in it's a men's room
yeah I walk in and you know there's just
some little bit of activity and then a
couple guys a couple stalls I'm like
uh-huh so I go I sit down won a lot of
you don't even pull my pants down just
sit down this stall all sudden I see
under the thing like three little
fingers come under there and then like a
little tapping foot and I'm like huh and
the guy he does it again and then all
sudden a little head pokes out from
under so this little 1097 and he's like
smiling like looking up at me and I'm
like I struggle though I'm like
they got me just don't know I walked
that guy out man
hey there was uh I'll leave this story
on this just because it's one of the
craziest things I ever heard so we had a
guy who he reminded me of like like
Bernie Mac he was just he was a he was a
Pio 100 I don't remember his first name
but he was just this elderly statesman
1098 you know what I'm saying
just a just a nice guy and oh he would
come in after church sometimes on his
day off just to see how is his officers
are doing and just always to the 19:01 I
mean like colored suits just look
perfect and just one of the nicest guys
so one day he had to like cover somebody
and work the third shift cuz like I said
there's only like two or three officers
there overnight they just kind of hang
on
make little patrols and once Wow and so
he's there on let's say a Thursday night
he does the overnight to Friday morning
Friday morning a guy was 1033 I think
was his er 10:30 his name was Chris but
30 was his number he he comes up he's
the first one there it's about 7 8
o'clock in the morning he walks up
elevator gets off the 10th floor
elevator opens there's a Pio 100 there's
Bernie Mac gentlemen of a man up against
the wall shirt just like ripped
untouched
breathing he looks to his left
and there's some just like shambles kind
of like Tweaker looking guy asleep just
laying there asleep he was the [ __ ]
happened here apo 100 caught this guy in
the store trying to steal [ __ ] about two
o'clock in the morning took him up to
the elevator to take him to the little
holding he hit when they got off the
elevator they started fighting and they
got into an all-out fight he got out of
his car for something he they got in an
all-out fight and they fought for six
hours no we had a fight like you tire
out actually pretty yea big once that
adrenaline saw it so they feel until
their adrenaline dumped and they're
exhausted and then he would the guy
would get up to go and try and get back
to you love it or take it out in the API
bag oh hell no get up and they would
just fight again for a while until they
were too tired there's tape take your
ass back down the guy would go to get up
to tag you back to your video to get out
why when he was down but you just cuff
him at that point I don't they were in
the middle of a fight I don't know me oh
my god maybe could get in the holy rooms
like I'm just gonna hold you in this
elevator and that's where you're gonna
wait can you imagine though fighting
somebody so long that it becomes a deal
where you're taking rounds like we got
let me take time so listen let's hit the
food court we'll grab a snack one the
dude that tackled a guy into the Doug
Fir yeah apo garza yeah was he like did
you guys watch this video and like
replay like 100 hundred
oh you got to see it Bo guards to take
this son of [ __ ] out
did he not gonna kiss it good oh dude
I'm sorry I said was he in there
admiring it he's got a real he's like
this is probably the only chance we
probably timed it up become at times
move up to the tree I got this did he
knock anything off the gift table
yeah they cleared the hole no code for
what I just saw is great what about the
Chocolate Factory did you guys you go
hang out oh yeah I mean we go it's still
that problems I mean Maisie Maisie zones
a now it was Marshall Fields when I was
there yeah but Macy's announced oh I
don't know if they've cleaned it out or
got it but literally it's like somebody
just kind of picked up in the 70s and
left
so there's weird decorations and stuff
but since it was built in the probably
40s or 50s the it feels even older than
that because it's just all this old
machinery and it's just straight-up
completely abandoned suppose the public
but you had access obviously because you
really go well yeah and and no you could
get people could find ways up into that
so we would sometimes have to close be
like hey we heard somebody was walking
around up there and like you were saying
we would have on the first floor people
would come in off that pedal for the
subway grab like three mixers and go run
around back yeah it the amount of
different things I don't know if it's
Marxist but I'm I'm currently writing a
pilot about my time there I mean thank
meets the office because you can't hire
or say it's like takes place in a Supra
but this is different that I don't think
cuz these are all like wannabe cops guys
it was yeah [ __ ] I don't know any cops
that would have done with those with
that 6-hour fight who's doing that I
think after a while it became a point of
fact I was like I'm not letting this
[ __ ] died and if you knew him
you know like what like that he always
had the nice like not too big but not
too small gold bracelet that kind of guy
just the perfect Arana Mike I told that
[ __ ]
yeah you know oh man dad and um what was
uh family matters
yeah you know I'm talking about Oh Carl
was it was erekle yeah god the dad yeah
the cop yeah you ain't also died hurt
all right I'm trying to help you out
here Roy love die hard favorite
Christmas movie uh what do you want to
talk about next
well okay it's list here we have oh well
I would I'd love to tell you guys about
the for well mancation is pretty great
so we talked about mancation like
buddies go up and get naked whatever you
guys what do you do we get we get naked
right away we drive up maybe 14
somebody's done that we we had a we had
our weekend like this is this is this
isn't the last one cuz we just just had
it but this is the one before and when
this happened you know those deals where
you're like I'm so pissed off right now
and then about a day later you're like
that's funny
yeah that's I'm using that so my buddy
Jeff so real quick if you don't know
mancation is when you and like why don't
you head it right right it's 16 guys and
we every year we go up to my family's
cottage just a little shack of a place
it's in our north and Madison Wisconsin
and it's the one time of the year that
we all get together about ten years ago
we were like hey everybody's moving and
you go all the way back to what middle
school these guys high school grade
school great school yeah I think the
least of us have known each other 20
years Wow and so we get together we do
this and it's it's fun we do themes
we've had C we did like a Mexican fiesta
once right and everybody just kind of
like dressed up we had a pinata that we
all we all had we've done the-- like
superhero themes we've done neon themes
and you just dress it whatever you think
that means to you and then we usually go
like tubing will go like an
all-you-can-eat fish and chicken it's
just it's just a good time to love it
yeah it's like that one weekend where
you're like you know this is really
gonna hurt but for the next two days I'm
yeah and so we go up there we do that we
had a year would I
this is how you knew that Jeff had
derailed so we're at we're at Jeff we're
at good old days eating fish and chicken
it's all-you-can-eat fish and chicken
German potato salad broasted potatoes
all of that it's good old days oh yeah
all the fixings is this open all year
round just in the summer all year round
but I mean that you know hitting time is
summer big time yeah so we go there and
I always feel bad because I'm like Van
Kirk party of 16 and you could just feel
like oh so they always put us in the
back looks like every wedding I've ever
been out with this group of friends were
always in the back they put us into like
the back corner we're sitting there and
were eating food and this poor waitress
you know she's like you guys need
anything else and Jeff's just like more
fish and she goes oh okay then one of
the boys like Jeff won't you be nice you
know the owner he's like what does it
matter she's just a bar wench
but he's hammered I mean we're all like
hammered and so uh and he's joking
around what day in the in the mancation
is this Friday okay David we end up at
Sharon Berg's which is a little resort
on the lake and Jeff starts playing [ __ ]
marry kill with women on the other side
of the bar and to the point where
they're like we can hear you and then
he's all real sorry about that so he
leaves we're back at the cabin and I I
do that you feel like Larson you're more
for one of these sickly you guys are
both in on this we would I walk into the
cabin I say who wants a beer I get four
beers four people want Peters but I
grabbed five walking back up ice pass
them around
and then I drop one in the fire unopened
and I'm gonna two guys see me do this
they tell everybody else
Korey and Brad see it and me and we all
kind of move back because we know in
about 10 minutes
ah yes plastic so we sit there all
sudden about 10 minutes in here embers
everywhere okay and everybody who didn't
is this like seven other guys there's
like freak it out everybody's freaking
out I look across the fire Jeff just
sitting there in a white patio chair
members on his legs
he's just sleeping not oh my god now he
he another deleting finish man so uh he
had another guy Mike they had gotten a
little room there like you know cabins
getting pretty cramped we'll just get a
room down at the resort so Mike's like
yeah hey man you got a like let's go
Jeff nothing out of Jeff okay
Jeff let's go now this is something
maybe you guys done booked you know your
love will friendship he goes Jeff smacks
him in the face
Jeff doesn't move because I'm leaving
you so grant goes and takes Jeff Jeff's
room so they leave and then we all leave
and we all go inside start playing cards
just leave Jeff out there all of a
sudden my buddy Brad Messer
Brad's uh Brad's happy brings a little
tent he has a little you know outside he
doesn't mess with anybody he goes guys
he comes running in guys ties and you
could tell by the tone it's not an
emergency but it's funny and nothing you
guys do not want to miss guys Jeff just
chris farley the table outside patio
table next to the fire and I walk
outside and Jeff is like he's like the
Creed guy coming up out of the mud type
deal and he's picking himself up off of
the off of the table and it is legs are
just in every direction off for him
going every direction the fires actually
gets like what are you what are you
doing and he's at that more I can't he
can't talk you know and then he just
starts peeing takes it out just starts
peeing starts peeing the backwards walk
towards the fire so I grabbed him by the
waist and I just spin him all the way
around and then he just keeps walking
and peeing then he walks to the side of
that he looked compared to the dude in
the bathroom you know he did some work
yeah he starts walking to the side of
the cabin and there's we have one of
those oh this is like old school but
it's a clothes hanger but it's
self-contained it's almost like a circle
like a like a looks like a up/down
spider's web this type of deal he walks
he gets stuck in it and his head's in it
is one of those arms
starts going around a circle for your
laundry yeah yeah he's stuck in a circle
like a broken merry-go-round
like going on this thing and then he
gets out and he walks straight through
the woods to the cabin next door and
these people are in there sleeping and
the world the wall that he's on is their
bedroom and I Jeff get back here and
he's like a Yeti like just doing the
full stride like through the woods and
then he gets there to their cabin and
just starts banging on the wall I walk
and I grab them I walk them back in the
cabin I feel right as we walk in the
cabin there's a pull-out couch Neil's in
there sleeping on it and I throw them
down in there and I go sleep here figure
nights over I go take a shower
what time of night is this right now
yeah 2:00 in the morning 3:00 maybe but
well I get in the shower
well I change I get in the shower I get
out of the shower I just get on my
shorts and the t-shirt and I just start
hearing bang bang bang bang bang on the
[ __ ] door how could this be having a
patient everybody's in bed so I walk out
and we uh we got a solid 35 inch screen
tube TV right and Jeff is at the end of
the pull-out couch up against with one
hand on it banging it into the wall well
cuz he's trying to steady himself while
he pees all over the wall and then and
then the speaker alright and now there's
also weedy trophies in our league and
there's a trophy and that's what League
Oh thing is the medication we're also on
a fantasy league together okay so one of
the trophies is like a big star like a
more unit the more you know type star
and that's like the point she I mean
it's right there though he's peeing on
that too and I go Jeff no walking up
and I tried to grab it he won't let go
of the TV and he knocks the trove and I
watch one of the tips of the stars go
down and into his shin you're like and
then he had that moment even to me where
I'm I'm mad it but I'm also like that's
really gonna [ __ ] hurt tomorrow and
so I throw him back down on the bed it
falls back down on the bed and it's it's
like the Bellagio I was gonna say I'm
like and I look over and I'm the other
couch is my buddy Aaron and I go Aaron
you see this [ __ ] and Aaron goes dude
I've been watching the whole [ __ ]
time I saw him when he got up to pee on
the video monitors man like thanks Aaron
Thanks
so then Jeff I swore to clean yourself
up he starts fighting with Neil Neil it
just got a beard now and Neil's like
that's my [ __ ] blanket and Jeff
starts are yelling I'm the captain now
from my dad and then he finally passes
out and the next day I get up and I'm
like you're [ __ ] disrespectful dude
and he's like oh I'm the bad guy cuz I
had a little bit of fun I'm the bad guy
now and I'm like you know he'd [ __ ]
clean that carpet up and he carpet up
there he's like he's like oh yeah he's
like oh I'll do it but I just don't
understand why I'm the bad guy because
I'm one guy here that wants to have a
good time
dude we've never ever let him live that
down that's like a small we have a
there's like a I don't what he a power
ranking of people who have gone nuts and
medication and he's he's in there but
he's not the only one no no everybody's
gotten into it but I mean at the older
you get the less you're having events
like this and there's always that one my
buddy oh and then it lasts for five
years
yeah yeah my buddy Eddie we went to his
house one time was all those four was
from college and we went to his house
he's got a nice house in New Jersey in
college he was Eddie and Monty and Big
Daddy and now he's Edward or Eddie yeah
yeah yeah he's been in the business
world for a long time he's doing well
one weekend we were all out there in his
house and he's like I will play wiffle
ball in the front yeah I did
little kids driving around he's got a
little like electric like pickup truck
you know and so we're just drinking
beers before yeah playing whiffle ball
the guys the girls are inside we're just
having a good time then I'm getting a
little tipsy and I'm like ah let's start
like we're in a nice neighborhood I just
start throwing my beer cans on the on
the ground like not like [ __ ] them
it's like let's trash his yard but then
he's just having his son cruise around a
little Jeep picking him up and then he
would say like he had a cool and
driveway like go get us some sodas and
he bring him sodas so we're just
drinking throughout the day this is his
house PS we end up at the fire pit out
back nice little fire pit he's putting
his feet up tips the fire pit over okay
he gets yelled about well like dude
dialed back is in come on oh come on
he's got the clip flops on so then we
get the fire back under control we got
him calm down
boom knocks it over again we're like
dude you're gonna set your own house on
fire that you've worked so hard to have
like he doesn't realize what's going on
next thing you know we see him go in the
kitchen we're all watching from outside
watching in he's like going through the
fridge like a grizzly bear snuck in the
house more fishing and then we see his
wife like come into the kitchen and just
stand yeah give it to him and we see him
like oh cool you see him start with his
come on to her I love that down playing
drunk level where you downplay
everything yeah and then you slowly saw
him like realizing that oh [ __ ] I'm
getting told right now and then like he
totally caught I think we put him to bed
and I think everyone else just hung out
but I was because we're like older and
you know he's like living like he was
the first one to have kids so like he
was dad guy before any of us and so this
was like oh we're let loose man I got a
plan he come late oh man he almost took
his whole house down I love that so this
cabin your family's cabin it's the same
cabin you guys had that adoption yeah
yeah okay so this is a fun story we had
a weekend if you guys ever had many
times in your life where you were
dealing with animals that weren't like
domesticated like like like you ever
like you've ever been on a farm yeah
like spent time on it we're like you got
to work with the animals and stuff like
that we
day I wouldn't call time I spent the day
we had a weekend we're up at the cabin a
goat showed up that nobody knows where
it came from or who it belonged to so we
just started calling it Gary Gary the
goat
Gary the co-opted Gary it's like Labor
Day weekend yeah we don't like we just
hang out and like we had a weave
old-school weber grill and after we get
done grilling oh look yeah oh hell yeah
the goat would get up on top of it and
stand there no way or something yeah
yeah and then Gary I like you but you're
crazy man
you're crazy you're crazy so they go
also seem to have a mild annoyance with
my aunt and uncle's tuba Sean's their
little dogs and these dogs were just
[ __ ] just like little shitty dogs and
then once while the dogs go out and try
and [ __ ] with this gonna go just turn on
RAM and just send them dogs and I hated
these dogs so one time that dog said
that they're that goat sent that dog
like 15 feet just rolling end over end
when he kicked them know if head bottom
and Ronald and my uncle Ken's got a bush
light in one hand he leaves this is also
this is also saying that is my first
fight but we can lead into that from
this so we we have Gary and Gary's just
hanging out man and then all sudden my
cousin Billy who's now he's a great guy
he's he's a pastor but it was but as a
little kid he really liked to set things
on fire Billy yeah yeah - goat Gary yeah
yeah well now that I think about it's a
great pairing because they have some
sort of like Billy could walk up to Gary
and just kind of put his hand out and
then the goat would like grub is Billy's
hands like his otherwise that go could
be dangerous
yeah how big was this a full-grown ho
man no baby goes yeah he's on top of
Weber he couldn't be too big he just
jumped like straight up on it and then
just stand there he it was a it was a
cool I'd probably say me with like 30 40
pounds time all right so uh okay man
hell of a chizel
now that's nice Gary's dead man so at
this time my cousin is dating a guy and
they have a couple of kids right and I'm
the weight they have a couple kids
together and they're just dating okay
the only previous marriage they have No
yeah oldest son
the first great grandkid in our family
I'm his Godfather
so he's it's my godson all right so my
godson's dad okay
he's there and he's one of these guys
that's like you know these people that
um I was it's pronounced theory cuz I'm
sure it's commonly known but some people
get in fights when they drink cuz they
they want to get beat up like that's
they they don't like themselves over
there yeah they got just demons and [ __ ]
you know what I mean like they want to
get hit like they want that and he would
do this thing where he would just walk
up to you and I get real close to me
like okay buddy all right man all right
what you get between Gary and the weber
grill you really I mean this was kind of
a thing
and like he's cutting your earlobe is in
his mouth good guy
you might be a good guy now I don't know
God hope he is I hope he is I don't know
at this time his life things were a coma
so you know what he was he was right the
thing is in my family we don't nobody in
the same is true for medication like we
don't have angry drunks
there's no nobody's like that in fun
drunks for the most part yeah yeah in
our people just drink until they're like
I'm gonna go to bed yeah and so you know
we kind of deviate imma turn in yeah we
are you dumping my real quick and I'm
like but I mean we just you know we just
don't have it so we even sit him like
hey man you know it's alright we're all
just having a good time you got some
shortcomings you guys are a good it's
Saturday a tradition of my family
Saturday's barbecue chicken so we make
the barbecue chicken Gary's out on top
of the grill and everybody's inside
doing like family prayer you know our
family prayer is just this little short
thing everybody says all-time we're
halfway through this is yeah yeah
halfway through this favorite prayer and
all sudden you hear is like half drunk
like picking it up the goats like and
he's like dragging him into like the
screen door and it like Gary's in the
carries like God he's going into the
abyss like he's like
yeah yeah so we get carried back outside
and and and then I'm like hey man you
all right just [ __ ] around everybody who
wants to have fun and stuff and I'm like
okay so then I go hey yes let's all go
to the bar
let's all go down to buffalo lake lodge
had you eat the chicken yet yeah we all
like okay so we're going on a buffalo
Lake Lodge and it is my cousin Gary stay
back yes you got the big day of kicking
the [ __ ] out of me tomorrow so we get to
a buffalo Lake Lodge it's like cheers
there's a style of Arts in the round so
it's in the center of the bar
everything's Ronna and then at the end
up at the front is a Connie cool and
cool Nancy and they're doing the karaoke
okay and Connie is a guy and he's known
to if he really likes your song he'll
jump in with his own microphone in
harmonica and start playing along with
you thank ya and then cool Nancy you
know she's just working the ones from
the tooth so wait if you're pumping and
you're not doing a good job you don't
get great he don't get I so we walk in
give me my harmonica it's like three of
my cousins so it's like it's like three
or four my cousins my one cousin and her
boyfriend has come and then it's my mom
and and we're all there ya know they're
back at the they're back at the cabin
with my hair with my aunt and uncle and
Grandma and we were all there and
everything and then I just noticed right
away like now he started doing this [ __ ]
with people at the bar right okay look
just maybe homilies waters for a little
bit like sorry about him and I'm real
sorry about that is I yeah I don't know
what that shit's all about me singing it
that's about the lowest film
yeah but you know what when a like kind
of like a guy who's on the custody and
an old timer it could still whip your
ass is he said something like yeah I
know what that shit's about you can't
that's his warning flare like I'm just
gonna let you know I don't know what
that [ __ ] you're like real sorry yeah
we'll go over here to the other side so
we go over there to the other side and
then they're like oh we got a we got
Danny Baker got here so I'm up there at
the front singing I love this bar
it's my I'm singing Toby Keith
everybody's going into it wait nothing
then he comes in though starts joining
me huh
harmonica right and we're all seeing
we're all having fun and then I walk as
I'm up there singing i watch i watch the
boyfriend walk around to the side of the
bar just kind of start like talking to a
guy walks over the top and I'm like am i
cool
yeah no different guy different guy so
then he walks back over and he sits back
down I'm like okay everything's good and
then I finished out the song and my
family oh yeah and I walk back down I go
down oh man to the guy he talked to hey
is everything everything all right and
he goes up I'm just I'm just saying you
[ __ ] offer to buy a man to drink you
better [ __ ] do it rather than say it
and walk away and I'm like you know what
sir I'll take care of drinking I'm
starting to feel like I'm babysitting
this guy this is it's not what we go up
to the cabin for right so then first
it's Jeff that's yeah Jeff's
all good just been where I've been
before too but they I go almost sorry
about that I'll buy a drink and but the
guys still like understand you don't
[ __ ] tell a man you're gonna buy him
a drink and then you just walk away and
don't do it and I'm like I'm really
really sorry about that so I walk over I
go up to the boyfriend I go hey man
come on did you lock this [ __ ] down he's
like you tell me what to do I'm like I
don't know drinking the whole time
well he's drinking whiskey straight
right and he also has a beer he's going
left so then he starts arguing with
these bowlers these guys had just got
back from a bowling league and and every
but to me everybody in a boy legal the
[ __ ] turkey has a past
I'm just bowling right now those days
yeah don't ask me what this tattoo means
so the guy one of the bowlers goes you
know that guy and I'm like well yeah I
mean I don't know he doesn't know how
old I am whether now he gives a [ __ ] but
I don't care what age you are you don't
[ __ ] with a Marine and I'm like okay all
right I look at my family I go we're
done we're done everybody out everybody
out I kicked my entire family on oh [ __ ]
is he doing also like that he went and
picked all the people that would
absolutely fight yes he didn't go to
fight he didn't go to one person in that
bar where he where they would have just
been like oh okay like they know who
every person to go to yeah yeah so I go
everybody out right and everybody leaves
except for the boyfriend and I go hey
man you're we're done here [ __ ] beer
I'm up for a spare right like the beer I
pound it
his beer I go you done you know you're
done and he goes tell me what you don't
like it's time to go dude and he gives
me the double push right yeah
so then I go Danny this is not what you
want to do so I just I wait for him to
come at me again thinking myself this is
not what I want to do but he comes at me
I grab him double hook I'm under both
arms because I had never been in a real
fight at this point in my life but I
wrestled for like nine years so I I know
how to move a person so I double hook
them under both arms I come walking in
like
Ben Ben comes flying back through the
door let's go oh my god Ben just holds
up the door I walk him out and I throw
him into the parking lot and it's it's a
gravel parking lot and any sunshine yeah
he turns out he goes
you [ __ ] do this [ __ ] to me I'm
like dude I just got you out of three
different fights in there I'll try to
have a weekend with my family
you brought gariand in the cash this is
enough man he's an outdoor goat all
sudden he kind of rips back comes round
hits me face yeah but I like ear side of
the hand ear you know yeah and then I
did at that point I don't remember a lot
but I just went and yeah dropped unload
on that face yeah now it's we're all
done
you've now you got your getting the
fight you wanted I'm sorry you had to
wait all the way until Christmas but
it's finally here yeah and so I I drop
him he gets up and he spits in my face
oh hell no right take my belt off and
choke no oh I heard a belt he earns I
got a belt right he earns it and yeah he
spits in my face I grabbed him by the
throat I put my right leg behind his
right leg so it's just kind of side
stuff him and I just boom right out into
that crown right then he starts to
strong with me and I grab I put one knee
into his ribs and I grab both his arms
and my elbows are like up by his face
and I'm holding him down there I got my
knee and as rizal hold I'm like he done
are you done
and I take that elbow and I put it up on
the side of his face and then I just
crank it over and I rub the side of his
face into the [ __ ] grabbing a parking
lot and I'm just holding it down there
what's your cousin doing this whole time
my whole family is like oh no one's
breaking it up no he's earned it and and
no one in my family I've you know I grew
up I'm eight years older than my
youngest brother I'm three and a half
three years older than my brother who's
just the one just younger than me and I
kind of had to we didn't have a dad
really so you live with your cousins for
a while didn't you they live next door
yeah yeah
and so and I've always been big I've
always been a big guy so I remember
being like 15 16 years old like I'm kind
of jealous of you having a twin because
you guys could probably unload on each
other yeah we did yeah yeah I knew that
if I ever unloaded on one of my cousins
and my brothers that'd be that they'd
never fight with me again because I
would unload on I was bigger than all of
them so I they've never seen me be
violent like really violent and like
sorry
no like we've wrestled around like well
like I would I would fight with my
brother but I would end up where I would
literally just hold him till the core he
couldn't move which is the most
frustrating thing but I never punched
them and so now I felt bad because
they're watching me punch this dude and
so I got him down like facing the thing
I'm like are you done is it you just
working that face into the side of the
thing and then I go I'm gonna get up
your ass better stay here or I'm gonna
get back on top of you and so I get up
and he like stays there for a second and
then my family throws him into with two
cars they put him in one of the car and
they drive off and now my cousin Billy
Billy with the hanging with Gloria and
my cousin Bobby they're brothers they're
like come on ride with us well before we
take off the owner comes running out and
and he's like cops are coming and I go
hey whoa I didn't do [ __ ] and he goes oh
no no no they're coming for him you can
have a job if you want work been working
there seven years No so we get into the
thing we get into the car
and my cousin Bobby's driving and he's
like he's a real nice guy and as I said
Billy Billy went on to be a pastor he's
a real nice even-tempered guy and like I
feel so bad guys I just still like so we
go over to the cabin I'm like no I can't
go to the cabin because it's just gonna
continue there like he's all hopped up
you know and he's back in the parking
lot still right they know they left in
another car so we're in separate cars so
I'm Bobby and Billy the guy who I beat
up yeah yeah he's my mom and my cousins
and they've head back to the cabin and I
go no way we can't I don't want to go
back there and I feel horrible and I
just keep saying that oh my gosh I can't
believe I did that
I can't believe I hit him I can't
believe I hit him and then my cousin
Billy goes what are you talking about
and I'm like and I'm rubbing my ear and
they're like what are you talking like I
just why would I hit him like that like
why would I start that fight and they're
like he hit you first I had completely
forgotten yeah then he hit me first so
then I was like I [ __ ] will go back
to the cabin whenever you want so we
probably I think we went to like another
bar had a couple waters sat her up for
like 20-30 minutes then we were back to
the cabin we pull up to the cabin we
walk up this [ __ ] comes up by
the grill so I just picture you pulling
the car in and the headlights coming up
and he's just staring they're like yeah
exactly right
he comes out of the front door of the
cabin and he's just staying bloppy and
[ __ ] yeah yeah shirt shorts on and he's
like hey man peace offering and I'm like
I we're good buddy we're good
and he goes no come on man I made you
this ham sandwich this just got a little
out of control
peace offering a ham sandwich and I go
all right man night I grab you know and
he's thinking you don't want you know
you're gonna eat it and I'm like see
here I'll eat your ham sandwich we're
good drank my beer
I take a bite out of a ham sandwich he
leans over just like you did earlier and
I'm like I put I slap on the back all
right buddy and I go wanna go pick rocks
oh yeah all right buddy
I go walk into the cabin I walk into the
front room we got the this beds out
there too just bad everywhere it's count
and I walk into the front room and uncle
in there like how happened I go now
they're talking to me while they're
laying one is they stay like that yeah
yeah and and the kids his kids are
sleeping on the floor like right in
front of me where I'm standing you know
and I'm like [ __ ] dude what nuts man
I'm like he tried to start three fights
why would you fight with an ex-marine
aka a bowler and two other people like
he's telling people I want to buy him
drinks I'm like it then you know I get
him outside after nothing nothing just
started fighting they're like oh my god
I don't know what to do and they're like
humming oh hey now he comes walking into
the front room right and he stands next
being bar and jelly you want any of this
pee I mean so he's standing next to it
hey man oh hey how are you and he's like
look some things happen I'm like yeah
you talk about Gary getting let into the
cabin because things happen they put put
everything behind us you know what I'm
like all right you know I'm sitting here
you leave these kids sleeping man you
know it's like you're connected to the
family you got
middle listen oh you're not married I
know that's a beef with everybody like
you were talking about yeah and he goes
no I wouldn't I go man why don't you
just hit the hay right you'd be good
buddy I'll show you some no I leave next
lace him and my cousin they sleep in the
front room one of the other beds as well
next morning
never never comes out of that room
never never comes out of that room at
all all right also my cousin comes out
of the room
everybody's been up for like two hours
were making breakfast out on the fire
and like we do on Sunday mornings she
goes haha well and I go well what she
was well my boyfriend just looked at me
and said we are never coming back here
again
and she looked at him and said you
probably aren't they broke up two days
later never got back together again good
for your cousin yeah I so I don't that's
what it took I think so I think it was
just her being like our place like our
cabins so special to our family that
they were like no and and I'll be honest
like that do you think I shouldn't say
okay but I don't know is it no I don't
even I wouldn't even it's not like
you're ever gonna
cuz he's still the he's still the dad oh
my god sense so I'm AB see Taurus while
and things been cordial and I hear the
things got better for him but that was
my first fight and it just you know most
fights it ends where it ends this
because of our cetera just kept you've
told two fights I mean well the six hour
[ __ ] fight yeah I mean I mean that
doesn't that didn't end normally yeah
and this normal what happened Gary man
did two weekends later Gary dead in a
ditch somebody hit you mean that guy
punched him probably was the drunk
driver I don't go many ulis drunk driver
wrote off the road and hit him up the
Weber oh that's sad I know but it's a
great like little chapter in my family's
life not so much the fight part but Gary
the goat we still be like oh my word
Gary the goat did he just hung out with
us for like three days and then he was
gone
it's like stand by me did you guys feed
him yeah oh yeah we'd give him little
stuff I mean it literally it was a
holiday weekend so it was like three or
four days of just hanging out with this
go unbelievable do you uh do you think
is this a story you could tell and yeah
we yeah yeah okay so this is this story
I love you guys a show cuz it makes me
think of like whenever I think was
throwing like I should keep that down in
case I get to God I love you three times
on the crab I know you listen to cuz you
even hit me up after all that crazy
stuff when I had particular on my show
was you know I tweeted out I said Ryan
Sickler is gonna be on the wahlberg
solution God knows I can't do this show
by myself God knows uh no I love this
show I love this show um so this was
told to me by a friend of mine named
Jack he he's a cop okay so one night
there's a Denny's over by Earwolf
actually it's on Sunset it's like sunset
in Van LOM I buy the one on one yeah and
they got they got a little lawn out
front
you know Denny's trying to look nice are
you guys diner people Oh first of all I
love diners I loved it I mean we grew up
at Denny's cuz okay one of my new you
guys
for Danny's - I used to get tapioca
pudding I mean really moons over my
hammy sub sausage like when Denny's
finally came into our area when we were
in high school that was the local that
was the late-night yang and [ __ ] but I
love diner in LA you go astro you guys
ever been Astro diner
I dunno Fletcher I know but I go to like
I mean I went to a diner this morning I
went to Maxwell's it's a diner oh is it
really though cuz there's a sunny spot
in Echo Park yeah $12 for a burger
that's not a diner no my opinon a dot at
a diner
everything should be within $3 of a 695
everything should be within 3 bucks of
695 no fries sad swingers okay Fred for
Fred for not dying they're designer done
yes yeah I want like wood paneling
there's I feel like I really like them
Baltimore like Greek diners yeah really
like going it's like Maxwell sets if you
feel like you're in New Hampshire it's
like you know it's like 2:00 in the
morning there's a guy going through a
divorce just drinking coffee yes like
diner yeah don't yeah I love them anyway
so this is a Denny's and it's it's late
at night it's like Friday or Saturday
night and like for Bros not a diner yeah
yeah it's a Denny's that's not a diner
that's a restaurant okay well they say
they're a diner vibe that's why I hear
you yeah yeah so we used to go under
there's a smoking and non-smoking
section they walk in I thought I was so
cool smoking another green on yeah which
is really smoking how many for for
smoking you say it's serious like right
into their eyes and they're like I got
to tell this guy you can't smoke in here
so this is Danny's four guys picture
like cargo shorts and visors and they
they go in they sit down it's late at
night bars are closed right and there's
four of them and one guy says oh I don't
want to eat here man okay and the other
three we're like come on dude like now
I'm gonna wait for you guys outside and
then we'll just walk back to the hotel
and they're like just will call him Chad
no no Chad just wait okay
so Chad leaves he says I'll be out front
there's like little benches out in front
Denny's well drunk dudes as they are
take their time you can eat a lot of
food they go out and they leave they
look at the benches he's not there
Chad's gone they're like he probably
just walked to the W or the hotel
whatever they're staying so they leave
and leave the diner about I don't know I
can't remember I don't want to [ __ ]
it but it's probably less than a half
hour maybe like 15 20 minutes they start
getting calls to 911 dispatchers saying
that there's a sexual assault happening
at the Denny's okay and people from
inside Denny's are calling and people on
Sunset of calling someone getting
aggressive with a grand slam back yeah
possible sexual assault right it's a 10
1 8 yeah yeah well what happened was the
Chad went and decided to fall asleep on
the lawn and a homeless guy came up
behind him and started having sex with
him yes Gary hold up the do passed out
blast shots and he decides we [ __ ]
them yeah yeah uh
this 10900 line for that guy's 1098
comes up behind him and and just kind of
muscles in big spoon style undoes both
their pants and just they're just having
sex on the front lawn people are calling
on sunset being like there is a drunk
like passed out white guy having anal
sex with a homeless guy on the front
lawn of Denny's right now there's a
weird Halloween display and Denny's got
to be in the homeless guy like that's
his lotto ticket oh he just found that
man
[ __ ] this well silly [ __ ] this
[ __ ] it right here - in traffic right
there on I know how to get it [ __ ]
hot me on a white kid on this venniese
law is what I call over easy so the cops
get there and then this is why I said
having said like did you not the cops
get there the cops get there and this is
why I said having sex because the they
were like hey listen sir you need to go
to a hospital right now you you need to
have like a rape kit an AIDS kit like
you've got to start getting medication
you probably need a plan B like we got
to get you know that water wasn't free
they charge you for the seat so he but
the guy kind of reacted like Chad was I
guess was very much like oh no
everything's good and they were like
alright everything's not good man you
just had non-consensual sex he's like
nah dude I was talking about he was in
denial so he was either completely delao
or kind of wet with it the cops really
it was murky the way that he was acting
cuz he was acting like he sort of knew
what happened but he didn't care to do
anything about it
and so they were like no you go along
with it because how odd is it wouldn't
you even if you weren't gonna eat and
you're at a diner with your friends
wouldn't you just sit there why would
you go out front
yeah maybe on the way in he's like I'll
be back to that guy gave him away
hey they can't get dolla number on the
way IOU bang well I feel like I should
tell you guys the truth that was me that
is the greatest prank
I'm the homeless guy ya know he he just
kind of was like I don't I don't know
everything's cool I don't press charges
they're like what like I'm he treated me
right they've been together six years
we're going bowling
in that crazy yeah [ __ ] could you
imagine driving down sunset Donna yeah
this guy's [ __ ] this guy right here
on the Denny's long oh man
you been walking out a bystander was
like did you see anything like that's a
whole thing man I just sad to watch Jay
one of things I love with you I feel
like you're good you know when to
stretch mm-hmm and I could see you
walking out of a Denny's post-meal good
night you just drank the night away or
ate the night away you know and you just
kind of give it a good stretch be like
check out this [ __ ] here on a
Denny's long oh man my buddies are cops
he told me that the people who responded
were like getting that call being like
what are you talking about and call
after call yeah coming oh can you
imagine sex on the Denny's front lawn
this has been a lot of [ __ ] fun man
we're definitely uh definitely glad you
came back
man that's our time obviously why don't
you plug away again okay just follow me
at Daniel Van Kirk the Wahlberg solution
happens every other month at UCB it's
usually the first Tuesday of every other
mother as well ease D so please look out
for that but you can keep track of all
that stuff a follow me
at Daniel Van Kirk and if you want to
check out character stuff and things
that I've done I have my own show dvk
I'm the Nerdist Network as I'm sure I've
told another episodes but people should
know Jay Larson and I have one on there
as well it's what's one of my fun it's
one of my most favorite things and yeah
that's it I'll be anyway at myspace just
Daniel vinkor and your podcast yes
you're right those things are important
hindsight where I have comedian friends
of mine come on they bring three photos
from any chapter of their life and then
we talk about the context of their life
when that photo was taken and then
Scarborough County that comes out every
Tuesday and that is with the Sklar Bros
and then the Wahlberg solution is also
podcasted on your walls so great
yeah man brother thanks man this was
great a lot of much love to do 1/4
responses okay yeah no I feel yeah dude
that was awesome I love having you
around love being around you get energy
as always Jay Larson call me calm Jay
Larson comedy now social media Ryan
Sickler on Twitter Instagram Facebook
Ryan Sickler calm they talk to y'all
next Tuesday